red leather yellow leather red leather
yellow leather red leather yellow
leather good blood bad blood welcome
back to the show that's one that i
learned in julia do the accent with it
do you have to do this no that was that
was standard american
blood that was standard american speech
uh or uh god what did we call it we
there was it really [ __ ] you up at
that school huh oh [ __ ] so stupid
what is a standard american
who is the standard american who set the
standard yeah who sets the standard for
what it is to be american somebody from
juilliard
oh man [ __ ] that [ __ ]
[ __ ] that [ __ ] man i don't want a
standard american sound like that
i don't either though
yeah i don't either no one does no one
does which is why when you first
graduate from juilliard you walk into a
casting and they go uh and how many
years has it been since you grab oh it's
been one year okay here we go he's still
gonna be talking like a
and robot in one two three action
guys you know what's funny
molestation
are you talking about the act or the
episode
neither
[Music]
we all watched the episode and i you
know the mcpoyles are great they're
they're super funny jimmy simpson nate
mooney uh so funny uncle jack you know
andrew friedman we were definitely at a
time where we were trying to do
something that we weren't seeing on tv
and what i'm realizing now
17 years later is that there was a
reason why it wasn't on tv yes it ain't
funny it wasn't that funny no it's not
that funny
i don't know it was funny to us at the
time yeah there's some fun look the idea
that your character is
upset that he didn't get molested that's
funny it's it's funny you know like
it is objectively funny it's kind of
understandable right like i think that's
what i like about it is there is a
reality to it as despicable as it is
there is a reality to being like well
wait a second if he's molesting those
guys
and those guys smelled like a couple of
quote unwiped [ __ ] as i believe you
put it in the episode my character
well your character sure um
you know then why wasn't he molesting
cute sweet
little old me the joke being that your
ego is so out of control that you can't
take not being blessed but if i have to
explain the joke you know this yeah
explain it if i have to explain it then
i don't think we shy away from from that
kind of stuff now i think it's just our
execution's different and most likely 17
years from now we'll look back on it and
be like wow i would do something
completely different well i would like
to point out one of the things about
that episode was that was the first time
that we ran up against some real
resistance with fx because that episode
was originally written to be not about a
gym teacher but about a catholic priest
and fx got a little squirrely about that
even though it was all over the news at
the time and it was a big deal in the
country and it was all over the world
really
and uh they got a little uncomfortable
with the idea of saying that a catholic
priest was molesting you guys even
though in the episode he isn't
molesting any of the kids
and even though
it was true because they were [ __ ]
the catholic priests were and still are
oh guys
you know
this isn't supposed to be uh
funny is it this podcast i mean no the
show is funny
the analysis man
it's like
okay megan is laughing and we gotta get
her a microphone i'm telling she doesn't
want it she's laughing are you guys
uncomfortable talking about fx being
uncomfortable with the episode and we we
almost we almost quit the show over it
guys we were about to like really [ __ ]
that would have been done oh it would
have been so dumb that would have been
so dumb no but i mean to our credit we
did realize that at a certain that you
know and to their credit we back down
well hold on a second to their credit
what they said was they said we
understand you guys are passionate about
this and we get it but will you at least
try
and see if you can make it something
else and see if it's still funny and we
were like well that's fair we would be
[ __ ] if we didn't at least try it
and see if we like of pressure that they
would get from the sort of catholic
powers
that is correct yeah they were worried
about the right let's go ahead and call
that out for what that is like that is
some dark [ __ ] to be like
we know that there's been a problem
we've been out here molesting boys but
don't you [ __ ] talk about it on your
tv show we'll destroy you like own your
[ __ ] man yeah own your [ __ ]
beg your forgiveness from your lord
and
do better i want to take it back to i
want to let's on a lighter note i want
to switch it over to uh jimmy simpson
and nate yeah they're the funniest part
of the entire episode jimmy and nate
though re-watching those episodes you
know like we had some stuff scripted in
there we had some ideas but they also
fully created those characters totally i
pushed them way further than what i was
sort of imagining on the page and
one thing i picked up on was nate
huffing the spray can
i guess i don't remember how this
happened but
three seasons later we had me just
puffing spray paint yeah but in the
first season we're like well this this
isn't a crazy character who does this
right
we also established in this episode that
you have sisters
yeah i have two i have two twin sisters
who see them never hear from them no
we had a grandmother and
yeah she must have passed by now okay um
um the twin sisters
we
completely forgot about like we scripted
them in and i say oh you know there was
some line about like them
and then we just kind of forgot that we
stopped you know who we didn't forget
about uncle jack oh man we sure didn't
do do you remember where we found him
yeah at the ground like yeah quirk not
quirk not say quick not mike
he did uh i played a character and i
don't know he had a oh then a parrot a
parrot oh yeah yeah named crooknut yes
and we're like this guy is funniest guy
i've ever seen and we wrote that part
specifically for him we did and he still
to this day
every time he pops up in an episode
there are very few guest actors that we
have that make me laugh as hard as
andrew friedman as uncle jack but two of
those people would be uh jimmy simpson
and nate mooney truly yeah very two of
the best but yeah we established all
those characters and that was the first
episode where we saw your mom too you
know we were we established a lot of
main characters yeah lynne marie stewart
marie stewart yeah brilliant was that
her first episode yeah i think that was
her first episode yeah she's so good
what's going on with you guys how are
things i saw you down on set earlier
yeah we're in the middle of filming the
15th season week two week two of uh the
15th season we couldn't get through that
scene that was fun
that was that was the first time we've
had a scene where i was like this is
really funny i'm i'm trouble getting
through it
yeah we got a bit tickled mall shooting
which is still the joy of doing the show
is that uh we make each other laugh yep
but what about the molested episode i
don't recall i don't recall a lot of
laughs
no coach belding from uh saved by the
bell principal building principal
principal belding yep yeah dennis
haskins
yes was our first celebrity guest
casting i think yeah history of the show
it's a big get
he's a big guest it kind of was for us
we're like
this is established actor coming in to
do our thing we went from that to danny
devito yeah yeah we did like immediately
like okay we we got dennis haskins and
now our next celebrity guest will be
danny devito i'll be interested to see
how much this show changes for us when
we start watching the second season
because i haven't seen those episodes in
equally as long and is it going to be as
painful as it is to watch the first
season no no no no no no it's definitely
a step up but it's a step in the right
direction as far as i recall there's
some really strong episodes in the
second season
i think what's strange is is like i
certainly don't want to go through the
entire catalog of the show and like
apologize for what we dig i think for me
it's more like looking back it's not
even about the content itself it's about
looking back
17 years in your life and you see
yourself like and you're like oh that
doesn't reflect who
the like who i am it's like weird you
look back at like home movies but it
shouldn't it shouldn't because you were
a man in his mid to late 20s and now
you're a man in your mid-40s it
shouldn't represent you now do you think
that's like that would be feel free he
feels that when if he sees jaws where
he's like ah this doesn't
just doesn't really matter
yeah but he doesn't he probably see he
just sees all he's probably got some
clunky scenes that he looks at and he's
like i wouldn't stage that one that way
anymore or something i wonder if we if
yeah we wind up having people listen to
this podcast and get pissed off at us
because they're like i like those
episodes why are you guys talking [ __ ]
on them and i don't think i'm talking
[ __ ] on them as much as like i think
yeah i think that's definitely gonna be
the case i mean you know they're like
bands that i love with they hate their
first album and i would argue it's their
best i think that's a classic tortured
artist perspective if i can call
ourselves that but like is that you're
just constantly trying to make the best
thing that ever was made right you're
every time you set out you're like well
this could be the best one that we do
maybe not 15 seasons in but um and then
you look back on you're like well it
wasn't the best thing ever made and then
you pick it apart
what's that spielberg do you still mr
spielberg stephen stephen
how do you feel about the first
jaws movie
i think it's pretty good i'm a big fan i
mean i still like it i mean i mean you
know
i don't love everything about it but
there's some things that i think still
work and i think i do regret that the
shark didn't look better because i still
think the movie would have been better
if the shark
if we'd been able to see the track more
but that turned out to be a good thing
according to some people i don't know
i stand by it i stand by it
i don't know is that bad steven
spielberg what do you talk well let's
have steven steven
how is your impression of yourself is it
good or is it bad i don't think i sound
like that
well
thanks for coming by steven spielberg
thank you thank you that was yeah steven
spielberg wow how good would it get
[Music]
how about this
when we wrapped the season
do you have any memories of how you felt
like once we were done like do you
recall that at all that you were like we
did it we got this thing in the can how
long was it from when we wrapped to when
we aired um okay well i remember the
last day we shot was actually we were
shooting the underage drinking episode
if i'm not mistaken we were we were on
location at the house where the big
party happens
and uh and i remember we busted out a
bottle of whiskey yep yeah you you sent
us a photo from that the other day
didn't she wasn't that bad yeah yeah i
definitely have a photo of the four of
us in one of our trailers like drinking
whiskey and
all right so we're all jazzed up we shot
a season of television
and
that and then what happened
then we
went into post and we we fell into full
despair because we had ruined it yeah uh
and then eventually we came out of that
and we had episodes that we felt like
pretty good about
right and we were like okay this is
different from other things that are on
tv like yeah maybe this will work i i
think i thought it was pretty funny i
mean oh no i felt great about it when
when we were done yeah the firs the
initial cuts no those are never good
but then did we do a premiere or
i mean
no no the we oh yeah we all went out to
a bar yes because they were launching
starved a show called starved
we went to like a tca thing at the
beverly yep and we watched it on like
televisions yeah and they had like big
screens in like the bar area yep and we
watched we were just talking and then we
watched while it was going because they
were drinking and eating at the same
time it was sort of like a background
band or something like that yeah yeah
yeah it was like a lounge act yeah
nobody was really paying attention to it
right and then uh that was it and then
we went to a big premiere that they had
for over there oh yeah
oh it's gonna be a monster yeah there
was a show that they had that they
thought was gonna be their big hit yeah
and it wasn't it wasn't it didn't work
they put it over there in the
trash yeah right over there in the trash
yeah and then and then then we proceeded
to not really see any promotion or
anything like that and then they put us
on at 10 30 at night on a thursday
mm-hmm in the summer yeah and so we
that was a big celebrated
and then we celebrated that by going out
when we left
we aired on a thursday yeah
oh right the night that the show
premiered we went to a bar in santa
monica yeah there was that that philly
box yeah the philly bar and we just
invited a bunch of our friends and it
wasn't like an official thing like it's
not like we it's not like the drinks
were free or anything and once again we
asked everybody to sort of quiet down
while it was on and the people of the
patrons of the bar were like [ __ ] you
get [ __ ] yeah i don't give a [ __ ]
about your stupid show yeah you're
coming to the bar to watch tv yeah and
then the ratings oh if i recall were
abysmal yeah yeah like uh pretty bad
pretty bad like nobody
yeah really nobody nobody watching but i
remember also being excited for some
reason we thought oh well no they know
what they're doing like maybe it'll work
and then we got a call the next day from
their publicity people and they were
like yeah so
right like no that this is like nobody
watched it nobody this is like that
nobody watched it this is really bad i
do remember that there was one important
statistic that we did okay and which was
that the people who did watch it
watched it through to the end yes so the
retention yeah retention
yeah they would monitor retention at the
quarter wave mark so every 15 minutes
right so if there was like let's say i
don't know throw out a number
175 people across the country who tuned
in uh 175 people watched it all the way
through to the end
and then we built on that and we built
on that from there but uh probably it
was danny
yeah well what happened and i guess
we'll get into this with the next
podcast but what happened was that
fx gave us a bit of an ultimatum when
they said look if you can get a big name
on your show and we can attract some
more viewers you're doing this so
cheaply that it's worth it for us to
take another crack at it i'm surprised
though that they didn't just
can it
like
why exactly they liked it they liked it
they liked it they saw some potential
yeah and i we we we were uh skeptical
about bringing out a new cast member but
at that point we were already talking
about meeting some of the parents on the
show so it kind of did go hand in hand
with that it's just the idea of making
that person a
regular cast member felt a little like
wait that's gonna [ __ ] with the dynamic
too much but do you guys remember some
of the names that we were throwing out
in terms of people that we thought would
be good to play dennis and dee's father
i remember one point where we were
talking about ray leo
i remember we got very serious about ray
liotta i just worked with ray leona i
know yeah he's lovely
he's the best
i think also maybe the fx was like well
you know who else gives this show a
giant thumbs up
the catholic church
no no problems no problem no problem
we're not seeing any problems so
we definitely i remember expecting like
a lot of pushback from whatever those
like
councils are whatever at the time at the
time it was the right that was coming
after uh television shows now it's the
left yeah that's sort of an amalgam of
of a number of different extremities
yeah yeah and then we were we were
actually kind of disappointed not yeah
nothing when it just kind of went
straight past it and our justification
was like oh well because people
understand satire they understand what
we're trying to do
really it was that they weren't watching
it no it wasn't they never heard of it
and i remember also i remember after
that first year that we put out a dvd
and blockbuster wouldn't carry it
they wouldn't carry it
[ __ ] blockbuster what do you mean so
glad they failed yeah they wouldn't
carry the dvds i don't remember that
yeah and it wasn't even content it was
because we just weren't like oh we oh
right
i think we released we're not a indie
film establishment here you know we're a
major blockbuster right it's called
we're looking for blockbusters i think
for years they didn't yard busters yeah
right yeah
they didn't carry about patio
my wife's parents mayor elizabeth uh
alice her parents the ellises are
sitting in the police station um when
yes they're just sitting on a bench
talking about they were in town visiting
her and they came to set to watch us
filming and we you know they were like
oh i don't know if they asked or if we
were like do you want to be in a shot
and they're like oh that'd be fun
i always felt bad about this you know
because they're from southern
mississippi very conservative part of
the world obviously and here they are in
this episode of television entirely
about like molestation right and
like completely unable to tell their
friends like oh yeah you gotta you know
watch charlie's show it's all about
yeah
here's a question for you charlie i
think i know what the answer is for you
rob but charlie
when you were making this show was there
a part of you that was like worried
about how your parents were going to
react to it
no fortunately really yeah um
i don't have that too bad okay yeah
thank god i definitely was i'm sure i
mean like understandably yeah i mean my
whole family is pretty conservative and
they're all christians and i just
thought because you know when you're an
actor you have the excuse of like you
know i'm taking a gig and i thought it
was cool and whatever but yeah i didn't
write anything i didn't create the damn
thing i'm just playing a character or
like whatever but like with this it was
like and that was always my excuse for
almost everything i did and then when we
created this show i was like well [ __ ] i
can't do that anymore so i guess i need
to tell my parents who i really am
so that's when i that's when my parents
discovered the real me
um
and you know what it was great actually
they were very supportive they didn't
you know what they did
my parents would always say like we just
we don't like all the geds can y'all
stop with it just if y'all could just do
the genies it's hard for us to watch it
with all the jd's in it and uh and it
just so happened that uh goddamn or
goddamn it was like my favorite curse
word of the time and probably still is
up there yeah that's a big one for our
show mike my grandmother watched every
episode and she would mute it oh yeah my
grandmother so she would just turn all
the sound down and then she could just
watch it but not listen to it which i
thought was really great she found the
content objectionable did she suppose so
she didn't really get into that as to
why she did that i just think it was
like i like looking at my grandson but i
don't need to hear what he's saying yeah
i don't need to hear this yeah i don't
need to hear this yeah yeah that's fine
just the i want to experience the
experience of seeing my grandson on
television that's exciting enough to
actually then go and listen to it that's
a whole other level that i'm not
interested in they're also from a
generation where children you know
didn't need to be heard at all anyway
yeah just seen right at the time right
my grandmother probably would have been
embarrassed that i even had the gall to
be on television like that i would even
think that anyone it's like that would
have been arrogant to her it would have
been arrogant to be like you just think
that people want to see you that's very
arrogant
that's very oppressive and withholding
of her yeah i have a funny story about
my grandma if you guys want to hear it
no okay no not really it's actually
really funny no please i'm not supposed
to go
i'm not going to tell you about my
grandmother but uh she was a very
conservative woman from mississippi
and there was this one time where my mom
was going to visit my grandmother when
she was in a nursing home and uh
she showed up and the nurse went to my
grandmother who we called me maw
and again this was the south and the
nurse went to meeman she said oh your
daughter janice is here to visit you
and my grandmother said
i don't have a daughter
i have never
been with a man
she she just yeah she was insisting to
the entire nursing staff that she
couldn't possibly have a daughter
because she had never had sex with a man
because that would be scandalous to
someone of her generation in her mind
what about the virgin mary you know like
does it do you ever think about how that
went she [ __ ] oh she [ __ ] come on
let's be honest virgin mary no she
[ __ ] everyone back then knew that she
[ __ ] that was her whole thing she
[ __ ]
oh should i not
sorry no that's all right that's all
right we got to make sure we clear this
podcast with the catholic church [ __ ]
them um
yeah
[Music]
well i'm sorry i interrupted you i i
interrupted you with my stupid joke no
no no my offensive joke it's i'm moved
past it okay were you going to ask a
question about the virgin mary that you
wanted a real answer to like what was
her deal
oh okay i thought you were going to say
like what was her relationship with
jesus i was going to go with jesus i was
going to go into a bed as well
she was his mother
right but i mean what was her deal like
did she did she love him was she real
was she overwhelmed by his thing
you know
was it like jesus had his own tv show in
a way and she was just embarrassed the
way your grandmother it was like it's
like it's like being julie cruz right or
whoever tom cruise's mom is she's just
like wow
how do i deal with this you know what i
mean my son is tom cruise
except her name is julie maphother
because that's his real last name come
on let's be honest map heather
yeah
no that's his real last name
i don't know if that's how you pronounce
it but that's never heard of such a name
tom matt
i do think his middle name really is
cruz though yeah yeah tom cruise
mapathor i would have gone with cruz as
well hell yeah yeah
if i had a time machine
if i had a time machine i would go back
and change my name as soon as i got out
right what would you change it what
would you i would keep it simple
dump truck you know rob dumpster
yeah
that's tough yeah that's cool very
masculine
oh man that's cool i would have been
like glenn boulder yes you know what i
mean you would have changed howerton
in a heartbeat you know what i would
have changed glenn to really have him
i'd be tom boulder
you know what i mean and then i would
have and i and i would have put on and i
would have hit crunch a little bit
harder than i did at the time in my
early twenties and i would you know
would put on some
i would have put on boulder shoulders
okay yeah i would have really put on
that i guess also yeah changing the
first name and if i would have went with
like gary like gary dump truck gary
dumpster here's the thing you're
remembering that name
right no matter what you're never going
to forget that name yeah you meet that
guy one time you're talking about him
when you leave the party gary dumpty you
[ __ ] meet that yeah did you want that
guy you're limiting not much to say
about his personality but his name
yeah but you're not getting a tons of
work as gary dumptruck you know you're
getting some funny like i have we got
gary dumptruck on the show again
but you know you're not out front and
center because they don't gary dump drug
does stand up he does something yeah
they don't want to put that on the movie
poster so let's get a different name
there yeah robert blaze
rob blaze yeah oh [ __ ] i had it's not
too late man
people still don't know who you are it's
not too late i know
i'm telling you man you could be rob
blaze now and no one would even notice i
had a nickname well i had a so
my freshman year of high school oh
okay our teacher we had a teacher who
said hey this was so [ __ ] cruel and i
was 14 year old boy so whatever she was
very kind enough to say like i'll call
you by your nicknames if you want me to
so when we go around you introduce
yourself you give a nickname
she got to me this is a story i've heard
before yes i've heard this yeah i
remember you were giving a [ __ ] about
like yes we never remember anything but
he's doing this for the podcast he knows
he's doing it for the podcast and also
because you said before you know that i
remember you told the story okay
but if i feel better i don't remember
i don't remember what the name is well
then you don't remember the story i
don't remember the story i just remember
that you told me the story i don't
remember the name either i remember the
story you don't know the story i know
the story i just don't know the [ __ ]
thing about names yeah but you took the
opposite side of it you took the other
side of the world i did but now i'm just
proving the point to you that you do
know the story insofar as you heard the
story but you don't remember the actual
events that is correct now go go with
the story i don't even know what you're
talking about right now i've already
moved on to other thoughts now go go i
want to hear it i've had 15 thoughts
since i last well i like hearing these
stories over and over again because
they're good stories now go go go okay
so she gets to me everybody's saying
whatever their name is or the nickname
when she gets to me i say blade
blade that's right i wanted her called
i'm just [ __ ] around cuz i'm 14.
she's like what's your name your
nickname and i said well everybody calls
me blade
and she was like
blaze and i at that point like didn't
then i was like oh [ __ ] like i i'm maybe
this like first day of school i'm gonna
get called out so i just said yes and
she was like okay blaze and i was like
all right and then and then from that
point i must have you registered it's
subconsciously pulled that up she called
me blaze for a long time i'm going to
call you blaze from now on yes i'm not
and that's not interestingly enough she
spelled it if she spelled it b-l-a-z-e
yeah and i'd be like all right that's
still kind of cool oh she's from french
race
maybe she's [ __ ] with me and then she
noticed that nobody in the school called
me blaze not a french teacher
and then we went back to rob who went
back to rob yeah so blaze did people
call you robbie at all when you were
younger robbie you know what they called
me i did have a weird nickname that my
wrestling coach called me oh boy you
guys know this i you of course you know
this this i don't recall it but that's
amazing
no
i was called squirrely d
squirrely d what was the what did it
call me squirrel what did the d stand
for robin be honest
these guys were south philly meatballs
it turns out that one of them was is in
jail and then got out and is now in the
witness protection program because he
was a [ __ ] gangster who ratted on a
bunch of other gangsters he was our
wrestling coach one of our rockstars oh
[ __ ] what did the d stand for though i
don't know like i said they were
meatballs who called everything like
tommy d and i was squirly d squirrely
why not squirrely b for like bob or
squirrely r i mean it doesn't sound good
d can only be dick that's what i'm
saying he saw they saw a little squirrel
in your pants and they were like what's
up yeah they saw you jim change it
[Music]
those singles
and look at that little squirrely deal
oh yeah yeah robbie's got squirrely you
know what we should maybe we should call
him a chipmunk it's a little smaller
than a squirrel oh yeah poor rob's got a
little squirrely d yeah
little squirrely
squirrelly d oh go get him squirrely d
out look at him try right well you must
have been good in your how much did you
[ __ ] weigh when you were right 87
pounds oh my god 87 pounds of high
school i know that for a fact because
the lowest weight class was 103. boy was
there like one only there was only it
was just you and one other guy it was
always the two of you wrestling because
nobody else could wrestle the 103 guys
and what yes
i got [ __ ] destroyed i sucked you did
well you shouldn't be wrestling someone
103 if you're 80 correct yeah well
there's not a lot of 80 87. there's
nothing 87 pound fresh and so your d
wasn't so squirrely you might have been
88 or 89 right right i have a 10 year
old son who weighs 90 pounds
i don't
understand 14 14 oh boy you you wonder
why i'm i'm telling my teachers my name
is blade i'm looking for attention
anyway you can get it yeah you think i
want to whip out my squirrely dick no no
i got too small it's too small you're in
catholic school it's too risky yeah it's
true there's something like that right
somebody might have started suck on it
and somebody
yeah somebody definitely would have
started something
always and those priests don't care how
squirrelly it is they'll pop that right
that's right
[Music]
well this has been fun this has been fun
guys um
[Music]
bye that's the end of season one but uh
tune in for season two
and much like it's always sunny in
philadelphia it seems unimaginable that
this endeavor could continue and yet i
think we'll just carry on
we're going to push through until uh it
becomes good or just continues to get
worse
bye
[Music]